this is Licari on one of the restaurants  that was targeted at the start of the  attack last night and you can see just  how close you can get to it I mean these  are locals and journalists but you can  step right up to the front the door  where the gunman first appeared you  could see the flowers and the canvas it  started to be placed and the sawdust on  the pavement which primarily was used to  soak up some of the blood and you can  see from the bullet holes here in the  window just how indiscriminate  this spraying of bullets warms and just  across the road is Liberty Kamboj a  Cambodian restaurant this is in the 10th  arrondissement which is close to the  center of Paris several died here as  well between these two restaurants 14  people